thanks to curiositystream for sponsoring
this video
when you sign up with a link in the
description you'll also get free access
to my streaming service
nebula in august 2020
something happened that has never
happened before
the u.s government threatened to ban an
app
president trump signed an executive
order making it illegal for u.s
companies to conduct transactions with
bite dance
the chinese owner of tick tock beginning
september 20th
unless it was sold to an american buyer
unlike the huawei ban
one year earlier which also invoked the
international emergency economic powers
act
this was a force to transfer and
involved something
far more tangible something millions of
americans use
every day and so began on august 6th
an unprecedented 45-day race to solicit
offers draft agreements negotiate terms
seek approval and finalize a deal the
likes of which have never been attempted
before
which companies would the trump
administration approve how would it
affect the presidential election
did bite dance have any legal recourse
how would a ban logistically work
and what exactly would a buyer of tick
tock receive the answers to all these
questions were fuzzy
it would seem the app would be split in
three one version for the chinese market
as now one for select countries like the
us canada australia and new zealand
and a third regular tick tock for the
rest of the non-chinese world
unsure of whether a deal would be made
tiktok engineers worked day and night
preparing to completely disconnect from
one of its largest markets at the last
second on top of this bite dance sued
the government in a last-ditch attempt
to reverse
or at least delay the ban adding to the
panic was the confusion around dates
trump continued mentioning september
15th despite already signing an order
for the 20th
and on august 14th the president signed
a second executive order
this time ordering bite dance to destroy
all u.s user data by november
12th american employees of tick tock
even wondered if they would still be
legally allowed to receive their
salaries
before a clarification was made despite
all these questions and complications
it actually did seem as though a deal
might be reached
mostly because its hands were tied with
nearly zero negotiating leverage
and a fast-taking clock bite dance might
as well cash out on its inevitable way
out of the country
but like a well-designed roller coaster
there have been alternating up and down
periods where a sale seemed either
absolutely certain
or utterly impossible sell but the
question was
to who the list of possible buyers was
relatively short because
a even with a trump ban fire sale
discount it would surely
be one of the biggest tech acquisitions
in history likely more expensive than
facebook paid for whatsapp or microsoft
for linkedin
and b the otherwise likely contenders
like google and amazon
are already under historic levels of
antitrust scrutiny
a deal this high profile would not help
make their case
at first it seemed microsoft and walmart
in a joint offer would take on that
unenviable challenge
although walmart sounds like a bizarre
match there are several reasons why it
might make sense
in china influencers or key opinion
leaders
as they're known there use the app to
sell everything from books to clothes to
makeup
the modern version of as seen on tv
infomercials
imagine brad pitt casually live
streaming about a product he likes
a mix of entertainment and advertising
chinese social commerce as a whole
is a 168 billion dollar a year industry
and if walmart could replicate this
phenomenon in the american market
it might be an effective way of
competing with amazon while also
positioning its brand as younger and
more relatable
together the two companies made a strong
pair microsoft
could credibly handle the technology
while walmart provided the business
model
the former even made a nod to trump's
request that the us government benefit
financially from the deal by vaguely
committing to economic contributions
the deal was said to be valued at around
20 to 30 billion dollars and appeared
imminent tick tock's newly hired
american ceo
even resigned around that time which
analysts interpreted as a sign in
agreement had been reached without him
but things took a different turn with
everyone focused on the specifics of a
potential deal
no one paid much thought to whether
china would approve
a full transfer of tick-tock to a u.s
company would not only damage its global
influence but
also and more importantly set a
precedent that chinese companies could
simply be forced to sell on command
and so for the first and only time since
2008
china's ministry of commerce and science
and technology
updated their lists of restricted
technology exports
the new items included quote
personalized information recommendation
service technology based on data
analysis
and artificial intelligence interactive
interfaces
both plenty vague enough to be applied
selectively
what this means is that bite dance would
need to request approval for the sale
from provincial authorities
up to 45 days in advance if it didn't
face an impossible task
before this change it certainly did then
it would now have to satisfy a buyer the
trump administration
and china simultaneously in order to
secure a deal
to highlight just how sisyphean this
task was
its ceo zhang yi ming was simultaneously
called a traitor
in china and a spy in america
not unsurprisingly microsoft announced
its offer had been rejected
and soon after oracle confirmed it had
reached a deal with bite dance although
it specializes in enterprise not
consumer technology its founder larry
ellison
helped fundraise for trump earlier this
year the company's current ceo was also
on the president's 2016
transition team the proposal submitted
to the trump administration
and eventually to authorities in china
would have oracle become the trusted
technology provider of a newly formed
tick-tock global
which it and also walmart could hold a
combined 20
stake in the new company would be
headquartered in the us
have an american board of directors and
hire thousands of new us
employees the app's data and source code
would be stored monitored and reviewed
by oracle in the u.s
while bite dance would remain in control
of the algorithm
to be absolutely clear this is a deal
not a sale by maintaining control of the
algorithm and engineers in the prc
very few of the original national
security concerns would be addressed
in essence oracle would be paid to
certify the security of tick tock
making it more like a glorified american
inspector or custodian
than an owner the deadline for the
original order was extended by one week
to sunday september 27th but whether or
not this proposal is approved
in some ways the outcome doesn't really
matter the precedent has already been
set
as tensions between the u.s and china
show no signs of
improving tick tock may soon consider
itself
one of the lucky ones if 2020 has been a
bit overwhelming
curiosity's dream is here to distract
you with hours and hours of entertaining
documentaries
and now thanks to curiositystream when
you sign up you'll also get access to my
streaming service
nebula nebula is a service made by
creators for creators where we can
experiment with new
projects and topics without fear of the
algorithm and free from annoying ads
you can watch videos before they're
released on youtube
in addition to entirely exclusive
originals like the youtuber game show
money hosted by tom scott so for less
than 15 bucks a year
you'll get access to thousands of high
quality documentaries
and nebula all while helping your
favorite creators do new and exciting
things
sign up today with the link in the
description